well perhaps not as influential as one
might be I do work in food I have worked
in food for 30 years my mission in this
world has been to get people to cook and
to demonstrate and hopefully teach the
cooking isn't that hard cooking of
course is a craft that we've seen a sad
decline in in my lifetime I used to say
that if i could get people to cook rice
and beans once a week my career would be
a success so my by that measure i have
still have a ways to go i think that in
the world of food things have gone sadly
and rather dramatically awry I don't
expect many arguments about that but I
am going to try to talk a little bit
today about opportunities we might have
to fix them or to at least make some
progress in this world it's not always
obvious from the food media but most
Americans don't really care which type
of salt they're using or whether their
tomatoes are heirloom most people as we
know choose convenience and quantity
over quality which has led to obesity
and goddess to the place that we're in
now which is not a good one we have a
two-tier system which can be represented
by shall we say artisanal parmesan for
some people and kraft cheese singles for
everybody else and this is no good we
have to find a way to provide these and
food for everyone we have to find a way
to implement a process that will teach
us how to buy food to cook through how
to eat food I appreciate food it's going
to have to get to the point at some
point where we understand the difference
between carrots on the right
the Cheetos on the left and beans and
rice over burgers and fries and so on I
have a friend who had some money so she
was working in publishing which is
everybody says dying industry maybe not
but she went to teach as a volunteer in
inner-city schools in New York and she
held up those kind of carrots and the
kids the kids either thought they were
Cheetos or didn't know what they were so
this was a few years ago maybe things
have gotten better but um that's not a
joke anyway everybody knows that the way
we're eating now has been nothing short
of disasters a third of the United
States population is obese and another
third is overweight and this is really
not a fat person joke obesity has become
one of our top 10 killers and at least
100,000 it may be as many as 300,000
Americans die each year from
obesity-related diseases so at the
current rate of growth almost everyone
will be obese by 2050 and at the current
rate of growth the death rate from
obesity will surpass that of lung cancer
by 2020 which is 10 years from now but
ironically it's lung cancer and the
anti-tobacco legislation it's spawned
that gives us a compelling model there
are tens of millions fewer smokers than
there would have been without
anti-smoking campaigns if we were only
that successful in cutting obesity rates
we'd save tens of millions of lives in
the 21st century in America alone this
is what will happen cigarettes as you
know we're nicotine delivery systems and
there's a sugar delivery system to one
that's legally marketed and sold without
restriction to children in schools on
street corners in stores even how far is
given to them by their parents cell
ladies and gentlemen I bring you a
public health menace that contributes to
more death than AIDS the flu murder or
car accidents soda
look discuss for a minute what soda and
cigarettes have in common one they're
both harmful and wasteful they're worse
than useless worse than useless is
pretty bad neither provides any benefit
beyond corporate profit and the
satisfaction of an engineered of an
engineered craving driven by marketing
and sometimes addiction number two
because of this their sales necessarily
depend on marketing budgets in the
hundreds of millions which is still a
lot of money despite everything three
they're profitable in 2008 coke made six
billion dollars Philip Morris made seven
billion dollars number for these profits
are borne by us not only because we're
the sucker is buying these poisons but
because we subsidize the crops that
produce them while we pay for the
enormous costs to public health and the
environment and finally five for the
good of all because that's what society
is all about they're regulated by law is
designed to decrease their consumption
well of course I lied five isn't true
soda is as unregulated as cigarettes
we're a generation ago a toll
five-year-old can stick a dollar in a
Coke machine and receive a jolt of
caffeine and sugar the rough equivalent
of a coffee with nine teaspoons of sugar
nine but if the soda is a 20 ounce size
its 17 teaspoons of sugar the annual
consumption of soda has gone from a few
bottles per person per year when the
crown cap was invented a little over a
century ago to 212 ounce bottles per
person in the 50s to 600 per person nad
at some point in the 80s soft drinks
became more popular than water these
numbers by the way don't include liquid
candy on carbon ated liquid candy like
Gatorade and the unspeakably I cannot I
wish I could say this more strongly
unspeakably cynical drinks like vitamin
water
which contains his third as much sugar
as cope add those together and you have
about a quart per person of
sugar-sweetened beverages day there's
the court the court contains about 300
calories and not coincidentally between
1990 between 1975 and 1997 per capita
consumption of high fructose corn syrup
which is the near exclusive sweetener in
soft drinks and which by the way last
week was found in one study to promote
obesity more quickly than sugar and even
fact the per capita consumption of high
fructose corn syrup in those 20 years
from the mid 70s in the mid nineties
John jumped from virtually nothing to 60
pounds a year found the week per person
which is equal to about 200 calories per
person per day roughly simultaneously
the weight of the average American
increased over twenty percent so we're
at the point where we'd have to eat
about 500 fewer calories every day to
return to the average weight of the 70s
I want to make this really simple not
that you can understand complicated
ideas weight gain is deadly most weight
gain is driven by increased calories
most increased calories come from fat or
sugar and sugar is the number one sorry
soda is the number one sugar delivery
system in fact so it is the number one
source of calories in the United States
Americans get an average of seven
percent of their calories from soda
every year which is more than any other
single food source American children get
half their calories from fat and sugar
and their obesity rate has more than
doubled in the last 20 years for
adolescents it's more than tripled you
can't call adult onset diabetes and you
can't call adult onset diabetes adult
onset diabetes anymore because so many
kids have it a quarter of obese kids
have high blood pressure high
cholesterol or other signs of heart
disease half the food eaten in the you
West today is now either takeout or
restaurant food but that doesn't tell
half the story because if you go to the
supermarket and you buy a bag of chips a
chocolate cake a frozen pizza and
mechana soda and you take that stuff
home and prepare it that counts as food
eaten at home so that's not in the fifty
percent of meals eaten in restaurants or
take out that counts as food eaten at
home and often in surveys service that
counts as cooking so the real numbers
and I'm guessing but the real numbers
indicate that something like ten percent
of all meals are cooked from scratch and
five percent of our calories come from
unprocessed fruits and vegetables
non-nutritive junk foods we've taken to
calling them UFOs or unidentifiable food
like objects or around every corner the
fact that we're hardwired to eat fat
sugar and salt and that today's food is
fatty or sweeter and saltier than ever
before is a deadly combination
especially with the world's biggest
marketing budget behind it and like so
many American cultural experiences this
one is being exported to the point where
for the first time in history over
nutrition is killing just about as many
people is under nutrition through
lobbying and payoffs that maintain
subsidies through a willful ignorance of
true costs junk food is cheap you can
buy five McDonald's hamburgers for five
bucks but even a really bad mcdonald's
salad costs 350 and the true price of a
cheeseburger is what no one knows but
it's at least 10 bucks and there are
credible estimates that peg it at 200
let's look at this for a second cattle
feed is subsidized by taxpayers it takes
a minimum of a hundred gallons of water
and 300 pounds of top soil to produce a
single burger you can't put a price on
environmental damn
you can't put a price on animal
suffering if the cow is raised in the
rainforest takes about 50 square feet of
clearance per burger many experts think
there's as much as one cubic meter of
unknown biodiversity destroyed for each
burger and I don't really see how you
can put a price on that but we can't put
a price on the cost of diet related
diseases it's roughly eight hundred and
forty billion dollars a year which is
way more than Social Security this I
think is interesting 40 years ago savvy
public health officials tried to tell
people they were eating too much and
eating badly but when they wanted to say
eat less mean the industry lobbied for a
message like choose lean mean when they
wanted to say when the good guys wanted
to say eat less fat the industry said
choose foods lower in fat and it was the
industry's position that got put forward
these are subtly different these
messages but what they all translated as
is it different but more and this is
part of the problem is that we need to
be eating fewer calories it's not only
that we need to change what we eat it's
that we need to change the way we eat
eating more fruits and vegetables of
course is a good thing but you have to
eat more fruits and vegetables at the
expense of the stuff that's making us
sick and what happened i like to call it
the snack wells phenomenon what happened
in the 80s and in the 90s is that if you
were choosing foods lower in fat it
didn't mean you were eliminating
high-fat foods and that you could eat as
many snack wells as you wanted to we saw
the biggest weight gain in history the
key to a sound diet is not only
well-known but it's obvious it's called
eating real food food that you prepare
yourself or even god forbid cook but big
salute can't make as much money on a
carrot as it can on carrot cake so we've
been trained through on cook we spend 20
times as much money in restaurants as we
used to i know people get numb for
numbers but I assure you each of these
numbers is pretty impressive we don't
teach our kids how to cook and our
mantra has become I'm too busy to cook
but we're busy in part because we spend
40 hours a week watching television and
increasingly and most ironically we're
watching other people cook this is
another one of the things that drives me
really bats I don't have time to cook
what are you doing i'm watching mario
not mario is the best by the way much of
this is well known but why pick on soda
why not UFOs in general they're all
almost equally guilty after all but
there are a number of reasons to pick on
soda we have to start somewhere so it is
low-hanging fruit as I said worse than
useless it's a major cause of obesity
and obesity is 2 diabetes what tobacco
is to lung cancer one studies shown I
mentioned this lady that shown in high
fructose corn syrup causes people or at
least sorry causes rats to gain way
faster than sugar does and faster than
fat does another studies shown that high
fructose corn syrup contains a compound
that can directly cause diabetes another
shown that calories in liquid form may
not make you full so they're easier to
consume thoughtlessly let's just back up
for a second and take a minute and look
at the tobacco Wars the correlation
between cancer and smoking was first
found around nineteen thirty twenty
years later readers digests yes
published a groundbreaking story called
cancer by the carton the US Public
Health Service denounced the causal
relationship between smoking and lung
cancer and by 1964 the Surgeon General
reported that smokers had a seventy
percent higher mortality rate than
non-smokers what the industry do the
industry covered up and the industry
diversified you may remember that RJ
Reynolds became RJR nabisco which ought
to tell you something about the food
industry
they invested in marketing Filter
Cigarettes for a healthier smoke and
they outspent public health messages for
thousand dollars to one they basically
paid professional Liars to deny the
truth this is a great video but the
death of hundreds of thousands of
smokers and nonsmokers each year was too
much to take and we know the results
packages were branded with warnings and
advertising was banned in nineteen
nineteen ninety eight in the 1998
settlement tobacco companies in exchange
for exemption from individual liability
cases agreed to curtail marketing
practices and pay about ten billion
dollars a year to compensate states for
medical care and to fund the NZ smoking
campaigns it's not a perfect solution
and it's not over worldwide six trillion
cigarettes are smoked every year still
half of all Americans who once smoked
have quit and our smoking numbers are
about half of what they once were
furthermore the anti-smoking movement
has built a self-perpetuating campaign
that's growing stronger as developing
countries recognize that lifestyle
diseases are more threatening than
communicable ones think about that you
don't need to smoke of course and it's
big food likes to point that you do need
to eat but you don't need sweetened
beverages tobacco is addictive sowe're
caffeinated drinks and even not and even
modern fatty salty sweet UFOs are
increasingly considered habit-forming
it's worth mentioning again once
developed diabetes never goes away so if
i say to you there's an industry that
hires experts to back up its specious
claims maintains it is in marketing to
children when it is endorses bad science
funds front groups lobbies like med and
claims that it's new
are safer and better and that it's
making healthier ones all the time and
then I ask you is that tobacco a big
food the answer is it's both big food
says that it understands that there's a
problem and wants to help us tackle it
by creating smaller portion sizes
reducing fat and sugar content
downplaying marketing in schools and
reducing world hunger by which they mean
exporting coke and Froot Loops these
efforts are at least better than their
so-called self-responsibility campaigns
which maintain that if you simply drink
less soda you'll be drinking less soda
but meanwhile they're going to try to
get you to drink more soda and if you do
drink more slow soda tough luck if you
get sick to me this sounds like someone
holding you underwater while they're
telling you to swim to the surface big
food claims they're improving improving
the nutritional quality of foods
advertised to children but the worst
products remain the most heavily
marketed and their so-called healthy
food often involves sticking a chemical
nutrient and otherwise nutrient for food
I found this in my parents supermarket
in Florida check out the label healthy
processed food as we all know is an
oxymoron if you have to label something
healthy it probably isn't Thank You
marion Nestle for that line going to
tell you a little bit about a failed
self-regulation effort that turned into
a huge victory for the anti junk food
movement this was the smart choices
campaign of last fall smart choices used
this momentarily familiar green
checkmark on the front of packages
ostensibly to show consumers which foods
met USDA nutritional requirements the
fact that these smart choices included
Froot Loops and kool-aid didn't seem
inconsistent to the industry or other
members of the impartial panel of
experts choosing them the impartial is
of course in quotes
you can see the little smart choices
thing here on your diet mug root beer
the cool thing is is the program was
immediately and widely damned and soon
enough are reborn FDA got involved and
boom two week later it was dead dead
this Timmy Utley signaled the start of
something big and I think we have both
the will and the power to move forward
we have some tools as well for starters
the little-known Toxic Substances
Control Act of nineteen seventy six
authorizes regulatory action on
substances if there's a quote and
unreasonable risk of injury to health or
the environment end quote now tobacco
was excluded from that which was perhaps
one of the niftiest lobbying moves ever
but junk food was not and since its harm
at ways its benefit it can be considered
toxic when we demonized tobacco when we
got little six year olds to say mmm I
can't do it sometimes i do a little
six-year-old voice when we got little
six year olds to say mommy daddy please
don't smoke I don't want you to die I
can do it sometimes but when we got
those kids to say that we changed the
way many people think about smoking soda
and other junk food must be similarly
demonized and big food must be held
responsible for what amounts to
unethical marketing to children who
obviously don't have the adult capacity
to resist and who spend nearly 30
billion dollars a year of their own
money on junk foods increasingly there's
pressure to reduce and counter that
advertising worldwide there's loads of
activity but the US should be leading
the way in this fight rather than
lagging behind okay so people often ask
me what we should do I think these are
the immediate initial immediate goals
um this is about as prescriptive as I
can be and I have little confidence that
these are more than pipe dreams but song
one let's reduce and then eliminate the
marketing of junk food to kids in fact
let's counter it Madison Avenue helped
create this problem and Madison Avenue
can help solve it too let's remove
vending machines from schools and let's
allow fewer vending machines everywhere
or here's a novel idea let's use vending
machines to dispense real food they're
not practical the watermelon is but a
nice graphic let's stop sponsorship of
sports or other school activities buy
junk food and let's take a step backward
let's make sure there's free water
everywhere we also have to look at
labeling the simplest solution is what's
called traffic light labeling which is
widely being used in the UK and is being
considered by the FDA this should be
accompanied by the removal of all health
claims from packaging and improve
nutrition labeling this is honest this
is honest labeling right here the school
lunch program needs to be overhauled and
with the childhood nutrition act coming
up for renewal now's the time I'd also
like to think about toning down the from
the garden local and organic for lunch
business which is all very nice but it's
not as important as what we really need
which is what we really need is an
all-out attack on obesity and that can
only be done by mandating menus that
meet strict nutritional standards that's
kids how about grown-ups we need
incentives for grownups to eat better we
need disincentives for them to eat worse
let's give tax breaks to retailers who
sell real food and so-called food
deserts and tax breaks to people who
purchase real
foods let's tax UFOs by which I mean
most highly processed foods let's make
chocolate chip cookies cause two dollars
let's make apples cost a quarter let's
make coke four bucks let's make water
free let's give people a break on their
health care premium as if they eat right
just like we do for not smoking and even
for good driving let employ professional
cooks to help those who are truly unable
to cook for themselves whether because
they're disabled or working too low
paying jobs to support their families
let's give low-income families basic
cooking equipment cheap or free let's
subsidize farmers markets let's double
the value of food stamps at farmer's
markets let's build a revived indoor
markets let's encourage the rec sale by
farmers by fishermen by hunters what
subsidize traditional farming rather
than industrial farming good ideas all
sounds very expensive but the payoffs
for all of this would be incredible and
we start by paying for it with the soda
tax the estimate is that a soda taxes of
a penny per ounce would reduce
consumption by up to fifteen percent
raise 15 billion dollars a year and then
quickly reduce public health costs by
five billion dollars a year don't have
to think this is a fantasy either the
soda tax is being considered in states
all over the country including so-called
conservative states like Mississippi
been and is being discussed by the
President and in Congress and there's a
recent proposal by the mayor of
Philadelphia to institute a twopenny per
ounce soda tax which would double all
those numbers I was talking about before
once the soda tax is inactive in a few
states the momentum will be unstoppable
and since the long-term goal is hardly a
Big Mac large fries in a bottle of water
we can go further and develop a
cheeseburger tax and we can do so fairly
this is my little depiction of the
Rainer scale which was developed in the
UK
and approaches objectivity and weighing
of foods benefits against its risks now
the Ranger scale says that camembert is
a bad food so obviously the Ranger scale
is imperfect but it's a start a ten
percent tax on so-called red light food
could raise hundreds of billions of
dollars annually while discouraging the
consumption of bad food and encouraging
the consumption of good food everything
changes I've long said well I've said
for three or four years if that counts
as long I've long said that if you were
to get ninety percent of your calories
from unprocessed plants the remaining
ten percent could be coke and Snickers
or Cheetos and you'd be just fine but as
I mentioned earlier our problem is that
we get five percent of our calories from
unprocessed plants this is what our diet
looks like largely because there is so
many heavily market and seemingly more
convenient choices that many people
simply can't choose foods that are good
for personal and collective health this
is the part of the talk where mr.
Pittman has trouble keeping
synchronizing the talking and the images
but you'll all enjoy this it's a parade
of choice big food claims to stands for
choice which of course is all American
but on an arena where most choices are
destructive we need fewer choices not
more choices and for every one of us
saying eat plants not junk we have tens
of millions of dollars screaming have it
your way the government needs to
counterbalance industry to help people
choose better we need fewer choices not
more the representatives of the food
industry who recognizes that this is
going to happen can profit by it it's
not predetermined that big food
continued down the same road as tobacco
they can diversify into food that
sustains health in the earth and by not
doing so they run the risk of becoming
increasingly regulated but even more
widely reviled what else can we do those
of us who work on food issues spend a
great deal of time discussing for
example whether grass-fed beef is
environmentally less destructive than
farm-raised fish or whether it's
possible to eat more food that's grown
locally and these issues are obviously
important but right now our main job our
critical job is to get people choosing
carrots instead of Cheetos to get people
cooking and to get them to eat in a way
that was once taken for granted that's
sanely thank you